hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong the weekly
podcast hosted by myself Mark Ellis and
Jacqueline Coley who is On Assignment
this week Jacqueline I'm really bummed
she's missing this episode because she
as she does Coast to Coast worldwide she
covers movies that are about to be
released and she got to do a number of
interviews with one of the subjects who
made the movie that we're talking about
today but not just that movie the three
movies that this person has directed we
are talking about the movies of Jordan
peel get out us and now no so Jaclyn's
doing a lot of cast and crew interviews
for nope going up to its release and I
know it's really exciting time for her
but now she's working on another project
that hopefully we can tell you all about
sooner rather than later some more
pre-movie release interview sort of
stuff so we'll get into all that but
today in lieu of Jacqueline Coley we
have two of my favorite recurring I'm
going to call them champions of the show
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong and we're going
to be talking about get out us and nope
just in context of the Tomato Meter the
audience score how we feel about these
movies when we saw them at the time nope
is still pretty fresh in our minds and
our hearts and how we look back on that
now and so this is going to be a really
fun Trilogy of Jordan peel movies I hope
we also have time to give some Key and
Peele love because it really is one of
the landmark sketch shows of our lives
so let's get into the introductions here
first up is fighting out of Atlanta you
know her from the pair Wade YouTube
channel that she created she is one of
my favorites for a number of reasons
Sharonda Williams is here Sharonda
welcome back to the show thank you for
having me I'm excited and scared at the
same time
it's it's interesting because you and I
we we last crossed paths at Star Wars
celebration I believe and so it was it
was right at that time in the year where
we're looking at summer movies and we're
talking about what we're really excited
about and I know that nope was both on
like maybe our top five list of like oh
we gotta see this movie and so I'm
excited to talk to you about this and I
also want to bring in our other
panelists today who needs no
introduction but I'm contractually
obligated to do it anyway you know her
from being a correspondent from
everything from E to NBC to here at
Rotten Tomatoes red carpets all across
the globe and she's been to the Met Gala
she's been a she's been an actual guest
at the Met Galer she's walked the stairs
folks it is the one the only miss Naz
Perez good morning Naz I love when you
say Gala first of all because I call it
the Met Gala and no I've never gone
inside Mark I've only taken like a
picture on the stairs I wish I wish I
was a guest at the Met Gala that would
be amazing well let me ask you
does it matter if you get inside the Met
Gala or does it it's just the stairs
pick is really all you need right
Sharonda it's just it's all on the
stairs it's just the state make you
survive the stairs that's all that
matters because some as we know for many
means they have not uh
I I should have a shirt that says I
survived the stairs at the Met Gala Mark
Ellis
so let's get into the the Tomato Meter
and audience score with these three
movies that we're talking about today
get out with such a a cultural
phenomenon it was a landmark movie
release and Jordan peels directorial
debut back in 2017 98 certified fresh on
the Tomato Meter with an 86 percent as
the audience score and then us was
released in 2019 that's at 93 certified
fresh 60 audience score you're noticing
a trend here and it continues with nope
earlier this year in July 82 certified
fresh the audience score is currently 68
what's so interesting about these three
movies that I just listed is that
usually especially with like a horror
sci-fi sort of tinge you'll see the
audience score be higher than the
critics uh saying on the Tomato Meter
but that's not the case with get out us
and nope so I'll start with you Sharonda
is Rotten Tomatoes wrong about any one
of the three Jordan peel directed films
that we've been treated to those far
almost definitely no no
oh no nah yeah no that we're definitely
wrong on that one it you think it's too
high yes okay very much so all right you
think nope is too high dude can we get
it into fresh territory in your mind or
are we going to be talking about a film
that you think is rotten oh I believe
that it is rotten
core yes this is gonna be good let's go
to Naz Perez here and you can stick with
notebook sharana did or you can talk
about us or get out is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong about any of these three films I
actually think they're it Rotten
Tomatoes is right about all three I
personally though loved the stories of
nope and get out over us
so like if it was like my own personal
ranking
um but I think Rotten Tomatoes is right
like the movies as a whole like I agree
with all those scores okay yeah and
that's a good that's a good point you
bring up about the ranking of the three
because it kind of goes in order of
release Sharonda do you agree with that
with that sort of ranking the get out is
a little bit better than us and then get
out and us better than nope oh yeah most
definitely I agree with the ranking okay
good well I just want to find some
common ground that we have before the
debate really sets in during movie talk
is I mean because I'm very fresh out of
the theater seeing nope and there's just
so much to discuss and think about
regardless how you felt about the movie
I do love when you see a flick and it
just it makes you want to talk about it
with your friends that have seen it
immediately afterwards so before we get
into that let's go to one of my favorite
segments because it gives me a break
from talking it is Tim Ryan our expert
review curation manager here at Rotten
Tomatoes is going to be telling us what
the critics were saying at the time of
the release of these three movies all
the way back to 2017 and as recently as
like I don't know a month ago so it's
time for two minutes with Tim
two minutes with Tim in a world where so
many films can feel like they're made by
algorithm thank goodness that Jordan
peel is making big bold provocative
tourist movies with ambition and ideas
to spare here's a brief run through his
work so far key and peel the TV series
that helped bring him to prominence has
an overall score of 97 on the Tomato
Meter and it has a 92 percent audience
score
get out from 2017 is certified fresh at
98 on the Tomato Meter with 399 reviews
and it has an 86 audience score us from
2019 is certified fresh at 93 with 554
reviews and it has a 60 audience score
nope released a few weeks back is
certified fresh at 82 percent with 316
reviews and it has a 68 audience score
in addition peel also wrote produced and
starred in Keanu a 2016 comedy about a
kidnapped cat which is certified fresh
at 78 and he co-wrote and co-produced
the 2021 Candyman which is certified
fresh at 84 so what did the critics have
to say about some of these films in a
fresh review for us Kofi Outlaw of
comicbook.com wrote us as Jordan Peel's
proud and confident declaration that his
talent and success is far from being a
one-time fluke there are a few
filmmakers who can so effectively create
entire worlds in their own unique
signature however in a rotten review for
nope Craig D Lindsay of crooked Marquis
wrote while it is refreshing to see a
filmmaker like peel swing for the fences
narrative wise it makes you wish Studios
would let more filmmakers take chances
like that some of it just doesn't land
so that's a brief overview of Jordan
Peel's career and for the record I want
to say I have a particular fondness for
the key and peel sketch that starts out
as a chaotic freestyle rap battle and
ends with Echoes of John Steinbeck I
laughed and I seriously almost cried
back to you folks that's a great call
there Tim closing us out on his segment
hopefully we get to talk about at least
one of our favorite key and key and peel
sketches as we sort of wrap things up
here on the show but let's get into
movie talk right now because there's a
lot to discuss Brian hit the music
[Music]
we have thoughts we have opinions and
Nas I want to start with you and then go
to Sharonda not necessarily getting into
the minutia of the films themselves yet
I just want to talk about Jordan peel as
a director of movies that are unique and
singular and aren't part of a bigger
franchise but that we still get excited
to go see in the theater I thought it
was really telling when I went to see
nope that the last trailer that aired
you know when you see the previews and
then we're like okay then we're done
with previews and then they run like the
hey uh don't forget there's there's Coke
in the lobby and then they have one more
trailer and it was for Oppenheimer the
movie coming out next summer directed by
Christopher Nolan and I really put Nolan
and peel on a short list that might just
be those two NAS where you get excited
because you're going to see a director
even though no one did the Batman
franchise now it's like more of these
one-offs where it's a story that we're
going to get immersed in and then it's
not going to tie in with numerous
sequels and prequels I I couldn't agree
more and I think a big uh reason why we
love peel and Nolan films because the
common denominator there is
cinematographer hoyte Van hoytma who is
just unreal
uh so yeah I so what was the question
mark
that was a great pool well it's just
that I think Jordan Peele might be that
guy for me at least and I guess I'm
curious as to whether he is that guy for
you and Sharonda as like it doesn't
matter what the movie is what the
premise is all I need to see is his name
under the director line on the poster
and I'm going to see it 100 I think like
for me what really gets me going in life
in general is novelty right and there's
a certain feeling you get when you go
see a Jordan peel movie you know you're
going to be hit with novelty you know
you're going to be hit with something
beautiful something you've never seen
before characters that you like want to
meet in real life not only is he an
unbelievable director he's also an
amazing producer he shines as an actor
comedian a writer the fact that three of
his films in a row the fact that his
directorial debut he won original
screenplay he won an Oscar for he's like
unreal and the fact that his subsequent
films after have all been fresh on the
Tomato Meter all in the high 80s and 90s
is crazy I think he's the king of the
modern classic I think he's giving
audiences quality Cinema that masses
love and I think that that is a really
rare category to be in I love that he's
telling black stories he's Reinventing
the horror genre his films are
artistically gripping not only are they
like oh my God they are stunning
visually to look at again in part we'll
talk about nope later and hoite because
I have so much to say about that but he
just truly is a Visionary and like you
were saying Marquee is actually one of
the most bankable original directors out
there
um the first weekend in theaters that
nope came out it got I think 44 million
in the box office and that was the
biggest box office haul for any original
movie since Us in 2019. so to me I'm
like yes he he is so up there and is
definitely one of the freshest directors
in Hollywood right now yeah and I'm glad
you you made the sort of the horror
sci-fi reference because Sharonda it
does feel like he is and he's been
compared to this and I think it's unfair
to compare him from an artistic
standpoint to M Night Shyamalan because
it was just a different time when
Shyamalan had the sixth sense and
unbreakable and signs come out but you
do think about that Trifecta versus this
one and it's like man you're you're
really impressing a lot of people is
Jordan Peele still the guy for you or
was he ever that guy I mean I still
believe in Jordan Peele right I mean I
think
I think Masterpiece is not gonna be this
great film and I think that's fine I
think that's how you become a better
creative
um I just think that I'm still gonna
stick in with Jordan pill
um but I do want to see something in
this next film that continues to remind
us of that feeling that we had when get
out first came out
um I think that like you said he's a
very bankable alone on his name and
especially in the time in the industry
where we're like literally thirsting for
fresh original ideas he's one of the
only creators out there who are actually
trying to find ways to push boundaries
and to really push our minds I mean if
you think about it there's not a lot of
films that you can go to the theater and
literally feel like you were in school
like you have to do like a whole
dissertation trying to break a movie
down like because that's what you want
you want to go to the movies to escape
to like go to another world to push your
mind to places that you never thought it
could go and I think that's one of the
reasons why we love Jordan pill why we
respect him so much and that's why there
are people who continuously have their
butts and seats every single time you
know he has a movie that's coming out so
I'm still I'm still alone for the Jordan
field ride I'm on the Jordan field train
I just you know I just I wasn't
fulfilling it it was a it was a rocky
ride for me compared to everybody else
with no yeah and I want to get into that
a little later but but we come here not
to bury Jordan but to praise him because
I want to start with some of the the
moments that we really love from his
movies and if we're saying that all of
our favorite movies is get out then if
if you say that was sort of the one
that's like oh this is like the new
director to watch what was it about get
out for you Sharonda that you said oh
this is why I love this movie and is
there a particular scene that you can
point to and you're like that right
there is when this movie got me I mean
honestly just the black perspective in
itself I think one of the reasons why
get out was a film that stood out so
much to me is it was it was a
psychological Thriller a psychological
horror of what it means to be black in
America of the actual horror that we
live day to day that's why things are
scary because you're just like these are
things that can actually happen these
are things that people actually
experience every single day and it was
in a way that everyone could kind of
relate or at least understand what it
felt like for Daniel Caillou's character
and how that might resonate with people
in America right now and is one of the
ways that you take something especially
when we're in such a divisive uh Society
right now where you can see how these
things can lead to more horrific paths
and I think that's why people really
just was drawn to it because as a black
person this is my life but also too and
if you think it uh L'Oreal you know his
mom on screen you're just like that is
how I would think in this movie the
comments that are made the passive
aggressive comments that are made like
this is stuff that people say in real
life and so he took away to take
everyday life and some of the horrors or
the thoughts that we have the crazy the
crazy scenarios that we can come up with
our mind and he found a way to bring
that into a movie that not only engaged
all audiences no matter what your
background was but he was able to pay
homage to the reasons on why we like
horror films why we like psychological
thrillers and it was just something that
we hadn't seen in so long and honestly
for me I never thought that we would be
able to see a horror film led by a black
lead that could generate masses from all
different demographics I thought that
that was exceptional
um and that's why I fell in love with
Jordan pill but I do want to say say
that Keanu walked so get out
Keanu Keanu was I had such a great time
in the theater watching Keanu too and
and you know I'm glad you bring up the
the cultural perspective the get out
showed not just because it's portraying
a a society of white people and I guess
my favorite part of get out is that is
the scene it didn't have or the
character it didn't have which is the
the white savior quote unquote where you
you would always think that oh there's
got to be at least one good white person
here who's trying to Buck the system
right no they're all inundated with
whatever is going on at the Armitage
Ranch and it's all bad stuff and if you
think that that's extreme then you can
go back and look at Myriad movies in the
past and see either if there is a
minority character at all then they're
just doing something that is very
surface level and and is more of a
stereotype than anything else and so Nas
when we see get out and we see even the
things that that the white folks say to
try to make the them relatable when they
say that I would have voted for Obama
for a third term or I love tiger talking
about golf it's like this is exactly
Jordan peel did a great job of putting
even me as a white person in in the
shoes of someone who feels very like it
very much like an outcast from everyone
else well I think that's why get out
with such a statement right because I
think the messaging there that that is
so true is that white liberals sometimes
think they're doing like the best work
and that their allies and and in doing
that don't realize that they actually
sometimes cause the most damage I think
and I that's what I took from that movie
and that's what I found was like such a
profound message along with everything
both of you guys are saying like it was
entertaining it was new the sunken place
like to create to create like such a
world and tell such a profound and just
like I don't know just leave audiences
with such a profound message and I don't
know I just I think like when the
trailer came out I was like wow this
movie's gonna be so good but I didn't
know that I was gonna walk out of the
theater like watching one of the best
scripts of the 21st century you know
what I mean and and his titles even like
get out and nope in particular it cuts
it cuts all the fat it's just like no
this is exactly how you're gonna feel in
this movie like if you're in that
situation nope I'm getting out or you
say you say nope you see something
hovering overhead nope I'm out and with
get out did you let me ask you this and
I'll start with you Sharonda just
because we are going to spoil even even
nope we're going to get into spoiler
territory there so a fair warning but if
you watch get out I am the last guy to
ever see the twist come and so I still
thought right up until the last moment
that his girlfriend Allison Williams was
gonna like be good and we try to rebel
against the crazy thing parents were
doing did you all see that coming before
I did I'll start with you Sharonda did I
see her still being evil did I yeah yeah
like her being part of this
indoctrinated culture oh yeah most
definitely yeah like no I mean and
that's one of the things like I I think
that's another reason why I love the
film right it never tries like you said
to have a white savior it never tries to
be like this person's gonna right this
wrong it's just it just is these are bad
people and they're gonna stay bad people
but I think but you root for the you
root for Daniel's character and you're
also excited when he actually gets to
win and that's where the fantasy portion
of it like you know horror is still some
type of fantasy but that's when that was
the fantasy portion for me because we
saw from the deleted scene of what was
supposed to happen with his characters
actually going to jail that that's
that's our reality so I think that's why
it was like in this film like we
actually get to win we get to keep our
lives like we get we get Justice in some
way shape or form and that's one of the
things that I loved about this film yeah
and and as you make the point that you
can really watch a movie that Jordan
peel does on multiple levels because you
can simply go for the entertainment
value and it will Rel is so necessary in
that movie Just because there's so much
heavy stuff going on we need some levity
like you you you take his quips and you
juxtapose that with the scene where the
maid is trying to force something out of
her to warn Daniel khalilian all she can
get is that single tier it it's a
dynamite combination no it's it's on
honestly I couldn't agree more
and the fact that you brought up Allison
Williams's character I really like that
you brought that up because for me Mark
that was like one of the scariest that
was for me like to like the pit drop in
my stomach that happened when she's like
you know I can't give you the car keys
right I was like
[Applause]
oh yeah I was like yep till this moment
that was I was like oh
f-u-c-k like it was it was chilling
even though now now the keys oh
be careful bro what the [ __ ]
I didn't do anything the [ __ ] is going
on
where are those keys Rose
you know I can't give you the case right
babe yeah the the only thing that I can
say that's negative against get out is
that it makes meet the parents seem very
low stakes because you you take meeting
the armitages and then you go back and
watch Meet the Parents you're like oh no
they just really care about their kid
that's all it is this isn't hard fence
door's not going through anything like
what Daniel kaluya went through it's
it's the it's the worst case scenario
when you're meeting your significant
other's parents and then you really find
out who your significant other actually
is so get out I think it's the top for
all of us in the 98 certified fresh and
the Tomato Meter indicates that with the
critics as well let's get into this nope
let's get into this stuff because again
I'm so fresh out of the movie and
sharada I'm curious for you because the
thing that I've seen with a lot of film
reviewers is when they're going back and
forth with people on Twitter they have
their opinion and then you you see this
phrase more often than not and it's you
need to see the movie again and
I saw the movie once and I think I got
some of the messaging but I was really
entertained throughout it as well is
this a film that in your eyes you'd
think you need to see again to get more
of it or are you just you saw in the
movie it is what it is and we're making
too much of this I'm
the movie twice
and the viewing
it was fun to watch the second time
because if any time you're watching a
Jordan pale movie for the first time
you're anticipating like what's the
catch what's the twist like what's
happening so then I can just go back and
watch this movie all over again and then
see if I saw the signs but I think
that's why the first watch of nope is
entertaining because you're trying to
figure out like what is happening what
is this thing that is happening to
everyone what is the catch gonna be what
is that fresh twist gonna be but the
second time watching it it was fun to
actually pick up on the cues that we had
from literally in the first scene in the
film but it didn't change my viewing
experience and if anything if the pacing
became worse in the second viewing
because you kind of know when
something's gonna amp up and when it's
not so I don't think you should ever
have to watch a movie more than one time
to get it I think that you can always
watch movies over and over again to find
more symbolism to find more little
nuggets of wisdom like that was you know
lodged in between the different scenes
things are in the dialogue but
we need to get out of this you need to
watch the movie twice or you miss the
point or you just you don't understand
Cinema these are all lines that I've got
from
now but it's just a lot of people and
I'm gonna get off my little little brand
but I think that the reason I'm compared
is to get out get out was great and is
considered a masterpiece because it's
very straightforward it's nothing that
you ever really have to think about is
really more of an enlightening film
because they take everyday things that
we do every single day things that we
say to people or joke about and they
kind of throw it in your face to
self-reflect and I think where as we've
seen the audience score go down on
Jordan pale films is when with the start
of us and now most recently with nope
it's very cerebral like you really have
to sit and think and Ponder and really
digest what you watch and I think right
now where we are as a country I think a
lot of people just want to go watch a
movie we understand like Clear Point
Blank what is it actually about and like
get emotion from us [ __ ] make us scare
and let us go home and a lot of people I
think would know the disconnect is is
that I think it was too much thought and
there were little things like character
development like actually fleshing out
these characters so we can fully connect
with them and connect with the themes
that Jordan was trying to give to the
audience and I think that's what we're
missing is just the basics everything
doesn't have to be this like
dissertation that we have to break down
after every movie we see like sometimes
we just want to be scared we want to
laugh we want to be fearful we want to
have a heart attack watching it and
that's it and I just think with nope we
miss that feeling it's it was too much
of reading in between the lines instead
of actually having time to enjoy what's
happened was taking place and unfolding
before our eyes
it sounds similar word as to to some of
the criticism that I heard Neil blomkamp
movies get after District 9 because that
came out and was and was such a a
critical darling and then you had
Elysium and you had chappie where it
almost felt I guess too heavy-handed
leaning into the social commentary
aspect of it and the movies forgot to be
entertaining I still loved Elysium uh
chappie I was very Luke warmond but do
you see nope as a movie that you can
just go be entertained by or do you feel
like did you also see the the commentary
of it maybe intruding upon your
enjoyment of the film I'm trying to work
through everything I feel right now
because my mind's working a million
miles minute because Sharonda I think I
agree with some of the points you're
making but I also like disagree I feel
like out of the three movies us is the
one movie and I think most people can
agree that you're just like well what
did that actually mean does it actually
mean that I'm my worst enemy are we just
you know I I know the Hands Across
America thing but I think that one was
the most like wait what is the meaning
here and I think the reason why we love
Jordan peel films is because they are
thought provoking I think that people
are getting smarter I think I think we
do want I think most people do want to
leave the theater and like Mark was
saying at the top of the podcast what's
so exciting about his movies is the
water cooler talk after and that's why
he makes it so fun to go to the theater
because you're like oh my God what did
you think what did you think what do you
think this means and I actually thought
that nope out of all three of them was
Jordan peel making a straight up
American UFO story with people of color
at the center which I think was huge he
made Jaws for people of color which just
was never was something that he loved
Spielberg he wanted to be the next Tim
Burton and he never had that growing up
and that's all he wanted to make and of
course yes there's there there is more
Nuance in
um what he was trying to say in the film
that I got that maybe not everyone
received but I I absolutely loved nope
nope is my favorite actually out of all
the three oh wow yeah it is because it
it has so much of what Naz loves in it I
love animals I love UFOs I love aliens I
love 80s 90s style I love 90s sitcom I
love Hollywood I love filmmaking I love
Western Vibes and Vistas I love young
fun characters that you can relate to
and it was like a whole mix of all of
that and I was like yes I just wanted an
alien UFO movie and my favorite part of
nope because the one thing I did agree
that you said Toronto was like the
character development wasn't fleshed out
and
um I think yes I think if the siblings
were fleshed out a little bit bit more
we could have like took to them and I
think most people could agree that
Stephen Young's story was actually like
the most evolved but that five minute
long short film Gordy in the middle of a
film was so epic it was horrifying it
was chilling it was terrifying it was
touching and I so rarely feel those two
emotions at the same time like
terrifying and touching I think most
people can agree that like we wanted to
see more of that and like I would
definitely just watch like a Gordy movie
a thousand percent but I think
ultimately I I love nature I love
animals this is a very personal specific
opinion on the film and the reason why I
loved it is is Hollywood sort of the oh
this overall arching theme of of you
know the lengths that Hollywood's
willing to go to for spectacle and like
how our relationship with wild animals
is human should be a mutual decision and
how very often it's not you know how
they were trying to make money off the
horses how Steven young you know was
making money off Gordy and how he didn't
learn his lesson and try to use the
alien UFO again for spectacle and for
money and how it was all about trying to
get the shot and it was just so I don't
know I was like God this is so smart and
such a funny cool stunningly visual way
of telling this story through like a
black lens I think it's interesting
because a lot of what she said I saw
like there's a lot of reason why people
liked it and one of the things that I
noticed in the reactions to the movie is
people was like oh it's like Jaws it's
like Close Encounters it's like Signs
and I was just like but everyone yes I
think it I think that his films like you
see his Inspirations you see who is
fired him to love films but I think the
problem that I'm having starting to have
and it started with nope is I don't know
what Jordan's voice is anymore like I
know the things that have influenced him
I know the creators that he loves but I
don't know specifically what he is
trying to say and what his voice is
going to be and how his voice is going
to be something that inspires other
people and I think that with no if we
just get back to like if we look at
basic filmmaking one of the biggest
questions Gordy is like something that
everyone was just like wait but I want
to know more about what happened with
Gordy and even with Stephen you and I
was like he was criminally
underutilized he literally had the best
backstory and it was just never like
they showed it to us and I was like oh
this is going to be good we're gonna tie
back into this I'm trying to figure out
what's going on with my home Gordy and
then it just suffers did anything with
it even with the character development
between the siblings it's just
I understand the idea of spectacle and
that's what sells this movie is
entertaining to watch you're long for
the ride you want to know what's going
to happen like so I think Jordan
continues to know how to engage his
audience before a movie comes out with
the marketing that they do on how to
engage people and I think Hollywood
should take note from that lessons
always more the less I know about
something the more exciting it is
watching unfold in the theater but I
don't feel as though
I think that this is I think we're
starting to give more credit to creators
like if you go back to the get out this
uh the get out all the themes and stuff
and I remember there's an interview
someone did with Jordan peel and they
were like oh so like were you talking
about this like was this the social
commentary about this and he was like
nah like but that's not what I was
trying to say and I think that I almost
feel with nope I think that other
people's theories are actually sound
more cool like what you're describing to
me sounds amazing like you got me
excited
but when I go into the theater I'm just
like I don't see this
but isn't that's what isn't that isn't
that what is so cool about art though
and like I think you bring up such a
wonderful conversation on do we need
does he need to have a distinct Voice or
can he paint with all colors of the
rainbow like I love Picasso's blue
period you know but I also love his
earlier stuff yeah because I feel like
nope more so than get out and us is a
movie where you are gonna you're gonna
bring your own stuff into that movie and
you're gonna leave with whatever
interpretation you had and I think that
it's perfectly left looser than that
because I've seen it compared to
everything from animal rights activism
to to to being a metaphor for Hollywood
itself and and that's kind of what I
took from it just on the initial viewing
is if you look up at this thing then
you're gonna get sucked into it and so
it's almost like if you're chasing Fame
then the machine is going to suck you up
but if you just keep your head down
literally and keep doing your work then
that might be more of a benefit in the
long run is what I took from it but I
feel like again get out is like hey this
is what we're talking about us I I think
Nas made the point it's it you might be
Your Own Worst Enemy and there might be
a weirder you that's living underground
for Topher Grace that person is me
um that's hilarious and and and yeah so
I think nope is it's the only person
though that I that to sharada's point
that I felt like was was sort of a
fleshed out character that I was like
this is a real person and not like a
metaphor for something was Kiki Palmer's
character just because she brought such
a an enthusiasm to the and and you know
when you have the sibling Dynamic you
always have that sibling I might be that
sibling that my other two siblings talk
about like that but it's where you just
have all this energy and this zest for
life and it it's it's a nice foil to
your your older brother who is just very
you know low-key and reserved so I I
liked the the way that those two work
together but you know to your point sure
Rhonda I feel like nope when you look at
the discourse of it I do like what
you're saying that you don't necessarily
you shouldn't have to go see a movie
three times to to get it and I'm just
curious for for you do you think that
that nope was as entertaining the second
time like did you still see the
entertainment value in it or and can you
just watch it on that level and find
enjoyment of it
you know what I mean I would
I was seeing how those around me were
reacting to it you know what I mean
um but I think that I was able to be
even more critical about it the second
time because there's some interesting
Concepts that are introduced especially
with the characters even breaking down
that that father-daughter dynamic you
know when he when Kiki's character tells
that story about how he wouldn't even
look up at her like he wouldn't even him
chasing chasing this money chasing
Hollywood like you couldn't even pay
attention to your child you know what I
mean and the importance of how her
brother what we think is sacrificing and
seeing her and sacrificing himself so
she can get out right but I wanted to
learn more about those Dynamics I wanted
to learn more about why is Daniel
kalia's character so like close off to
the world like what was that upbringing
like they show a picture of their mother
like what happened to their mother like
there's a lot of questions that I still
have about these characters that will
help me understand why they do the
things that they do why they behave the
way that they behave and even with
Steven's character like you know him
really just pushing really blocking out
this traumatic thing that happened to
him just in instead using the fame that
he received from going through this
terrible childhood trauma and just
totally missing the point of how I mean
which leads to his stuff but that's a
whole different story I just think if I
ask anybody who says that they love it
hey what's the plot of the movie
can I ask you questions they're like I
mean you got a point they're like yeah I
don't know what was happening like I
wish we would got more things about that
but I think hey but that's another thing
shout out to Jordan pill because
everyone just loves the spectacle of
what he brings to us that no one acts
these just minor like clock details
character details like somebody tell me
what was I supposed to get from that I
didn't think the movie has anything to
say outside of spectacle I just don't
think it has anything deeper to say and
how the characters relate to that
spectacle or how they relate to the idea
of when the spectacle like becomes
bigger than who we are as people I don't
know that the movie necessarily has more
to say or like everyone in my comment
section I missed the point I don't know
what what did you think about like the
the mention I know it wasn't a huge plot
point but the horse in motion and how
you know there's so many black people
who have contributed to like Hollywood
who were never credited and and we don't
even know about them like I feel like
that was also like he always sort of
tries like I love the lens that he like
tells black stories through if that
makes sense because I I had no idea
about that yeah I feel like we got an
education I always feel that way walking
out of his movies I I don't know if I
felt that way with us I feel like the
second act of us was my favorite when it
like wasn't deep actually and was just
horror and comedy but from get out and
nope which is why I think I love them
the most I do leave feeling with like a
mo with like a larger perspective on
things
I think that that would have been a
bigger like tie-in like a larger yeah
yeah like if it's kind of like yeah
we're gonna hit you with some facts in
the beginning but like we never really
come back to that and I don't know if
even at the end the fact that when the
the news crew shows up and Kiki's the
one that's gonna be the one to go talk
to them or whatnot like that is going to
be like the black people survive this
terrible experience right that people
are I don't know if they could and once
again that could be me just making
something more into what it was supposed
to be and I I think that's
where I get kind of weary right now
because sometimes I just think that we
are giving cool ideas and cool
backstories but I don't know if that was
necessarily the intent I think that we
do the we do films a little bit more
favors than we should by finding ways to
make sense of something that really
wasn't there in the movie Let me let me
ask you all this so one of the scenes
that I really enjoyed in nope was the
the total it's the proverbial horror
movie what's that noise oh it's just a
cat where kaluya's in the barn and
there's something wonky with the power
and then the alien fake out these creepy
little aliens and I was like what is
going on and then it's just like the
kids it literally is that Jaws thing
where it's just the kids swimming around
with the fake fin trying to scare
everybody Naz Sharonda did you all think
that was an actual alien or were you
like no this is too early in the movie
for this I thought it was an actual
alien because I'm the most gullible I am
the most gullible herbal easy to please
Sharonda something you should know about
me I love rotten movies like I I just I
love and you know what's so funny how
you you've been mentioning seeing the
movie a second time my immediate thought
was like I cannot wait to watch that at
home while I'm high again like I I had
so much fun watching nope and yes Mark
that was like to me that was one of the
funniest moments to alien fake out the
funniest moment to me in the whole movie
though I I maybe you guys can because
you guys have seen it recently and
because I saw it a while ago now and
shronda I know you've seen it twice and
I don't remember exactly what Kiki says
but when Holst The cinematographer like
agrees to help them and she goes to
Daniel and she's like didn't I tell you
we were gonna find the best in
photographer and then they like Clap
Hands yeah I laughed so hard I don't
what does she say in that moment again I
just thought it was so funny because it
was so real and grounded and authentic
and like how two people trying to get
this shot and trying to make it happen
would feel and it just really put me in
the movie It's the five high fives the
boom boom yes all right it's like a
black I like black people did so we get
so excited about the smallest exactly
that's what it was it was like seeing
that black Joy on screen you know and
just it was so funny that's like the car
when he locks it when he like he looks
like he about to get out I was like I
don't know you're not gonna get out of
this car then we looked and then he like
locks the door I'm like baby what is
locking the dolphin to do with a whole
spaceship or whatever
but yeah I mean there's Great Moments
yeah it's it's great fun moments like I
laughed Kiki like how can you not laugh
when Kiki just spreads Joy she should
literally get a Nobel Peace Prize like
for spreading Joy
but that is that is such a great call
wait wait we give great performers
Oscars Kiki Palmer description
she's such a leading lady and if this
movie proved anything it's that she she
is a lead you know and she captivates
and I just can't wait to see her do more
and more and more because she is the
most Charming in this film like you
can't just help but love her but I think
that's the see everyone gives Jordan
pill Flack because he said they were
like enjoy the people say he would never
cast the white weed in his movie but and
that's the thing like you know even with
the Keke Palmer discourse that we've had
on social media because it's crazy to me
that people are just now discovering
Kiki because like my girl was like one
of the first black people black women
with like a like a Nickelodeon show or
Disney show like she's been doing music
she's been starting TV shows she hosted
a talk show like she's been in all these
things since she was a kid but people
are just now starting to notice her and
I think that's why it's so this these
are moments when we talk about
representation because there's so many
other talented people but you just
continue to see the same complexion the
same type of actors who get to do every
single movie and I think this is why
isn't important for us to have creatives
of color to have people in the board
rooms that are people of color because
it's just we're laser focused on either
the the white male leader the white
female lead and it's just crazy because
we're missing out on all this Talent
like if if Daniel kaluya was not in get
out he would not be a Academy
award-winning actor right now like
really think about that because I we've
seen him he was in some he was what was
that the show that he was on that
everyone's like famous and I was like
this like why a type of show he was also
in Black Mirror but it's like without
get out if get out never happened I do
not think that we will know the talent
that Daniel has and that's what really
makes me sad and I feel like those are
the stories that we have to tell like
you have to put it like that I know that
sounds crazy like Sharon what are you
talking about without get out he
wouldn't be an Oscar winner but it's the
truth it's the opportunity it's setting
yourself up for the opportunity and and
if you don't have a a sort of a comet
hit like what get out was in 2017 it
create it's a great movie but it also
creates a Wellspring of opportunity and
that's what Studios look to capitalize
on they're they're in this to make money
they're not in this to make art they're
in this to make money and when you see
that you have a director like Jordan
Peele who's made this immense profit off
of a movie and gained so much clout and
critical praise then you do say okay
well let's see what what other stories
are there that we're missing before and
that's why a movie like get out is so
important and I was just gonna say
that's why it goes back to why I feel
Jordan peel is one of the freshest
directors because he Champions fresh
voices like you were just saying and
that is also why I love nope and I think
nope is essential and we need just a
regular American UFO story with people
of color at the center and the fact that
he made that and that you know little
kids are going to see that like and
that's the summer blockbuster for them
like that's it just it's so much beyond
the box office and art in this podcast
you know Jordan Peele is obviously comes
from a very comedic background and has
had tremendous success with key and peel
when we see his movies there's there's
always going to be suspense and and
horror and sci-fi and and possibly
messages to be taken away but you get
great comedy as well you get amazing
comedic moments even within the context
of a scary movie so I would point to us
it says one of my favorite combos of the
two Winston Duke's scene where he's just
trying to be the tough guy and he's got
the baseball bat and he's outside
yelling if you want to get crazy let's
get crazy that's an all-time highlight
for me as far as how you can marry
horror and comedy not just in the same
movie but within the same scene now I
thought I already done told y'all to get
off my property okay so if y'all want to
get crazy we can get crazy
now the cops are already on their way
hey hey hey hey
Naz Sharonda do you all have a scene
that Jordan peels directed that you say
that's great comedy even if we're being
scared at the same time
think that Daniel character is like
about to meet his demise and then you
just see his friends I mean even the
phone calls because literally those
phone calls like when he tell him like
man like what are you doing like that is
what your friend would tell you that's
what you're screaming at the yelling at
the theater screen at that time is is
those like little Outburst moments where
you like kind of bring in real life like
what you're thinking is actually what's
being said on the screen that's
hilarious to me he's different no why is
he dressed like that it's not that it's
everything
I came to the party with a white woman
like 30 years old now sex slave
oh
[ __ ] Chris you gotta get the [ __ ] I'm
out of there man you want some eyewash
situation leave [ __ ]
no you're gonna be us hello
Chris oh oh [ __ ] this battery must have
[ __ ] died comedy and horror they're
really the same to me because you go to
horror movies especially the bad ones
you go to laugh when someone Falls like
you wait for the person to trip and fall
out of nowhere when the Killer is about
to like get to them like those are the
things that like make a horror movies
fun everyone laughing in the audience
someone getting scared and people
laughing at them being scared I feel
like horror and comedy are really one
and the same that's the best Nas is is I
love seeing a horror movie where
everybody gets scared and then two
seconds later in a pack theater
everybody's laughing not because there's
a joke necessarily but because we're all
laughing at each other for just getting
that freak out laughing yeah I I'm with
you guys like to me comedy is horror
like I laughed I and I have such a
horrible like dark sense of humor but in
nope when this was such a random moment
too which is like I don't it was kind of
unnecessary but I thought it was so
funny when Steven Yeun sort of like
reveals the horse and we see the
audience and his old co-stars in the
audience and her face is all messed up
I was like why is she here and I laughed
out loud because her face was messed up
and then even holds the cinematographer
like just because you know like he was
so into Hollywood and then he just wants
to get taken in because you know like I
thought that was so it was so funny no
man I was so mad at this thing I said no
sir
hammer down
so they can get the film I was okay kid
I take it you're sick you're taking
pills like you sacrificed yourself and
and just throw I thought you're gonna be
like here guys like yeah all right but
here's the footage
when he was in the car and that you know
like the carnival whatever horse fell on
the truck he died laughing and the whole
Fry's Electronics of it all like this
disgruntled retail worker you know I
love electronic stores that made it feel
really nostalgic for me and like put me
back in time
um which is why that's a real thing
outside fries is is fries really does
have that UFO you can go to the one in
Burbank I think it and and it really
does have it looks like a UFO crash
there yeah and so I mean that's just
that's Mana from the filmmaking gods for
Jordan field to be like oh yeah we
definitely got to go to Fry's yeah and
it was so genius to like include it and
like all that stuff makes me laugh you
know like it's so it's so good uh
wrapping things up here thank you both
for being here today uh Sharonda I hope
we get to see each other in person again
sooner rather than later where can all
the kids find you uh and all the stuff
you're working on with payer weight and
what does Sharonda have for us what do I
have well first you can find me on
social media and especially YouTube at
pay or wait uh Naz you're always doing
wonderful things even if you're just
walking upstairs and not actually
getting into a venue you still shine uh
Coast to Coast where can everybody find
the stuff you're working on and uh you
got a streaming show you got a movie you
want to tout
um yeah so you guys can find me on
Instagram at nazpres or on Tick Tock at
NAS interviews and I am just loving this
fourth season of what we do in the
shadows I don't think people talk about
what we do in the shadows enough I think
it is the most brilliant comedy on
television for vampires that lived
together in Staten Island like produced
by taika watiti and this season they
like start a nightclub there's like a
vampire rapper there's like a baby like
it is so hilarious and well done and
nandor's kind of like a bachelor this
season or like he's like looking for
love and just it is so outrageous that
you can't help but laugh out loud I
think it's one of the best shows on TV
right now and I get so excited
um every week when it comes out and you
talk about the marriage of horror and
comedy this one
but you can email us uh whether you have
thoughts about this episode previous
episodes or you just have a movie a show
that you think we need to cover on
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong because it's
been done in Injustice by the Tomato
Meter hit us up at RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and so with that for
everybody here at uh the great Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong Endeavor I'm the least
crucial part of the operation but I will
tell you you that I have upcoming tour
dates this fall at
markellis.live kicking off with Vegas
September 5th through the 11th at the
MGM Grand you can go see me there and
for Jacqueline Coley for Brian Perez for
Lucy Bruckner for everyone here at
Rotten Tomatoes for the sweet pug the
dude who is now sleeping like a good boy
I am Mark Ellis thanks for tuning in to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong and we'll see
you next time don't look up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]